la presión ucraniana hizo que las
fuerzas rusas abandonarán gerson pero la
población paga por ello han quedado sin
energía eléctrica y sin agua a puertas
de un invierno que ya se siente con
intensidad
mi calefacción trabaja con electricidad
y no hay electricidad qué hacemos
estos puntos de recarga eléctrica son la
única alternativa de la población que
busca restablecer la comunicación con el
mundo exterior durante meses estuvieron
completamente aislados del resto de
Ucrania
la gente más cercana a mí se fue no
podía llamarlos Pero eso no importa
los que se quedaron intento al retomar
su vida como pueden como Iliana que
lleva todos estos meses apoyando a
personas mayores que necesitan de ayuda
para sobrevivir
ellas no pueden hacer nada por su cuenta
Así que desde la mañana hasta la noche
tenemos trabajo
esta mañana le trae una caja con ayuda
humanitaria a Sofía una doctora en
biología de 93 años
no electricidad no agua no calefacción
hace frío pero vengo todos los días a
cocinarle algo y lavar
Sofía pasó la mayor parte de la invasión
en este sillón durante meses la radio
dejó de sonar y su única compañía era la
lectura de algunos periódicos viejos
ahora mismo No es fácil es miedoso pero
tengo fortaleza
en la estación cientos de personas han
decidido dejar la ciudad en los últimos
días
[Música]
las autoridades lo sonrían invitado a
abandonar Durante los meses de invierno
pero la mayoría los que llegan hasta
aquí No lo hacen motivados por el temor
al frío sino los ataques rusos que sean
intensificado estamos muy preocupados
tenemos pesar no queremos irnos porque
es nuestra tierra nuestra casa Esperamos
que sea por poco tiempo los chicos harán
su trabajo y regresaremos a casa con el
paso de los días en gerson aumenta la
expectativa sobre el destino que le
espera a la ciudad